una Van Patten more pour parler de la
doula the love up the last su France
demoon de
you cannot overcome a pandemic of this
speed and this scale without the truth
and the truth is that Europe has now
become the world's beating heart of
solidarity the true Europe is standing
up the one that is there for each other
when it is needed the most
the one where paramedics from Poland and
doctors from Romania save lives in Italy
where ventilators from Germany provide a
lifeline in Spain where hospitals in
Czechia treat the sick from France and
what patients from Bergamo are flown in
clinics to Bonn we've seen medical
supplies go from Lithonia to Spain and
respirators go from Denmark to Italy in
fact we have seen every piece of
equipment go in every direction across
Europe from whoever can spare it to
whoever that needs it this makes me
proud to be an European event Yadin half
a pound I would in Bihar a Vieira
identify so knudsen labelled threatened
when the lady was called lambda I will
pay or not are opiates we should see we
need unprecedented measures to do this
and to make sure our economy is ready to
bounce forward as soon as possible
we've made our stated rules more
flexible than ever in the last few days
alone we have approved schemes that will
provide 1 billion euro to Croatian
businesses 1.2 billion for Greek SMEs or
20 million to Portuguese fishermen there
are many more examples I could pick from
Latvia and Estonia to Belgium or Sweden
for the first time in our history we
triggered the full flexibility and the
stability and growth pact along with
bold measures taken by the European
Central Bank this provides unprecedented
fiscal and financial power and the last
week's decision by EU finance ministers
mean a further 500 billion euros will be
available to all of those who need it as
out of all this action to Europe's
collective response is well above three
trillion euros this is the most
impressive response anywhere in the
world but we know we will need more a
lot more
we need a Marshall Plan for Europe's
recovery and it needs to be put in place
immediately there's only one instrument
we have but a trusted by all member
state which is already in place that can
deliver quickly it is transparent and it
is time tested as an instrument for
cohesion convergence and investment and
that is the European budget the European
budget will be the mothership of our
recovery if we all stand up for Europe
today with courage trust and solidarity
I know that tomorrow Europe's so will
shine brighter than ever before